come on be honest who came up with
somewhere between the power lines and
palm trees I think Brett did I would
look out over this Reservoir and all
there was was palm trees everywhere and
power lines just going between them and
no water in the reservoir remember yeah
and the whole thing was just super LA
and super like nature versus man and
coexisting and it just I took a picture
of it which is the album all the shots
were from that area in Silver Lake and
more palm trees more power lines and
more birds and just sunsets and weird
streaks of light coyotes everywhere yeah
it was just one of those kind of things
yeah yeah I would get woken up coyot
crazy yeah just yeah but it was fun it
was just see what happens when you make
a coyote sound you die
man